bp-boss from sweden
sweden let's see if you can get another
variant as usual yes as usual
with i5 i haven't had such great
experiences
what else can we play so
now let's go an
accelerated kite
that i have ages ago plays scales
so don't know me really well from
this breeding at that time five has the
main advantage that somehow provokes the cups of white
so the short castling then you
don't have to be annoyed or annoyed with all these long
bookstore variants around
it but at least you do
n't have to worry too much about it  do
so of course now played very
directly yes
springer 4 then comes later to six
and springer ii 7
so important almost dead not yet i
could play toni eight
as a move for example
to cover the seven first
cracking a scheme
that is not surprising  we
the 2
i thought now the knight was the four
then he has to take lä in the bishop  shore
takes so takes then i still have
a piece a few way in the position
so you have us for example
yes good i don’t have the bishop anymore anyway
ok
knight each 5 is still to be
considered how do you like the simplification
already so so important  it ca
n't be wrong
and swapping would of course be good
for me i have a good endgame
so and now he needs a
little more time so he can't
play f4 right away
and i still have a few more moves the
question is i would like to  also
get rid of it if it somehow works that
still have the door and about lady
maybe loosebie 5 it's about the
in the officers
produced also the daytona goes away
sitzmann called 5 made surprisingly he
can take it here now and then
do that or that's the catch
so
think but listen think also now
take
but that's the endgame or not
so good good doesn't
mean somehow super great so black is okay
mine  me with that
i somehow think that you can get the
black majority here in the center
that he always quick as
what knows he has, among other things, through the
double pawn
i should get
the space advantage here with the center
it's probably thoma 5 and 1 b
play 5 or maybe b5 straight away
can also be
his power to play the five c4
c4 yes i believe
god again two minutes less
for totally simple moves
sometimes it is better to play instead of storing
and sometimes is that you can do the
idea
super
e5 again  or still
b54 yes that sony do i have to be a
bit faster here
i have to rely on the king's activity here now
assume that the farmer is
not that dangerous hopefully
i'm right with
it the way it is just here now
play actively do
n't look at the material so much
I have 30 seconds
yes
, I don't care yes I know you can actually do something here
make you stand really active but
yes I always only have the
active position but
winning somehow should also be
difficult probably
still many bosses from behind
fell asleep completely in the game